welcome everybody i want to start today
with another republican senator who is
saying something so uncontroversial but
it becomes controversial because of how
radically authoritarian the republican
party has become but also even though
he's saying something true and
uncontroversial he's not our ally he's
not our friend he's still a radical
republican senator i know i'm being kind
of cryptic in the introduction but
there's really three issues here issue
number one is it's become controversial
to say that joe biden really won issue
number two is that former president
donald trump continues to be triggered
like a little boy anytime anybody tells
the truth about the 2020 election and
issue number three is we should not be
confused these aren't our ally
republicans they're radical republicans
who accept an uncontroversial fact if a
republican said
we need water to live we wouldn't say
they're our ally we would say no we
agree about something completely
uncontroversial and they are still
radical republicans so let's get right
into it so that you will understand what
i'm talking about
republican senator
mike round
uh he appeared
uh at rounds fl uh plural that is he
appeared on sunday with abc's george
stephanopoulos and he said in very un
uh ambiguous terms
that they lost the 2020 presidential
election this isn't news to you
it's not news to me but there haven't
been that many republicans that speak
this clearly so let's take a listen to
what mike rounds had to say
here we go
you heard martha raddatz's piece right
there how do what do you say you you
voted to certify uh the election last
year you condemned the protests as an
insurrection what do you say to all
those republicans all those veterans who
believe the election was stolen who've
bought
the falsehoods coming from former
president trump
we looked as a part of our due diligence
we looked at over 60 different
accusations made
in multiple states
while there were some irregularities
there were none of the irregularities
which would have risen to the point
where they would have changed the vote
outcome in a single state
the election was fair as fair as
we've seen
we simply did not win the election as
republicans for the presidency
and moving forward and that's the way we
want to look at this moving forward we
have to refocus once again on what it's
going to take to win the presidency
right actually trying to convince people
that it's in their best interests to
vote for you if we simply look back and
tell our people don't vote because you
know there's cheating going on
then we're going to put ourselves in a
huge disadvantage so moving forward
let's focus on what it takes to win
those elections we can do that but we
have to let people know that they can
they can believe and they can have
confidence that those elections are fair
and uh and and and that is in every
single state that we looked at so this
is not controversial this is a senator
simply saying we lost
we lost that that's all that happened
there were not more irregularities than
there typically are
they didn't affect results in even a
single state we lost and we've got to
figure out how to win so number one is
that's controversial among many
republicans at this point in time
roughly half of whom still believe the
election wasn't really won by joe biden
this gets us to donald trump's response
this uncontroversial statement from a
republican which it being controversial
is part of the story
triggers the former president to no end
within
a few hours of this happening very early
yesterday after this statement came out
on sunday donald trump puts out a
statement
quote senator
he puts it in quotes senator mike rounds
of the great state of south dakota just
went woke
on the capital f fraudulent presidential
election of 2020. no he didn't
woke
it he just said hey we they got more
votes and therefore they won
he made a statement this weekend on abc
fake news that despite massive evidence
to the contrary including much of it
pouring in from wisconsin georgia
arizona michigan pennsylvania and other
states there's no evidence pouring in
guys he found the election to be okay
just fine is he crazy or just stupid the
numbers are conclusive and the
fraudulent and irregular votes are
massive that's untrue the only reason he
did this is because he got my
endorsement easily and got my
endorsement and easily won his state in
2020. so now he thinks he has time and
those are the only ones the weak who
will break away even though his election
will not be coming up with for five
years i will never endorse this jerk
again
it's rhinos like this remember rhino
means republican in name only
it's a term they use to mean
they have an r next to their name but
they're not really a republican there's
a litmus test now for trump if you
believe he really lost you're not really
a republican trump writing it's rhinos
like this that are allowing the
democrats to destroy our nation and then
he goes on with the normal stuff the
radical left democrats and rhinos like
senator mike rounds don't make it easy
for our country to succeed he's a weak
and ineffective leader and i hereby
firmly pledge that he will never receive
my endorsement again
so second part of the story is
this is a former president an adult by
all by all technical measures
who
is relegated to sandbox playground
insults anytime somebody says something
that's uncomfortable uncontroversial now
the third part and this is the really
important part is these people are not
our friends these people are not allies
liz cheney adam kinzinger they recognize
joe biden really won great but you
shouldn't get a pat on the back for that
that's just reality it's like
recognizing the sun rises and sets you
know um
but they voted with trump almost
exclusively cheney and kinzinger
and similarly mike rounds is a radical
republican he doesn't get any praise
from us
we note that it's wild that him saying
biden won
is out of step with the republican party
but this guy is no friend of ours he was
one of the 22 senators who signed a
letter telling trump to pull out of the
paris climate agreement
he supported remember scott pruitt from
the epa who was caught spending insane
amounts of money on luxury travel for
his fam like a completely beyond the
pale mike rounds stood by scott pruitt
rounds opposed the first step act which
was one of the few okay things that
donald trump actually did as president
he has voted to repeal the affordable
care act multiple times
he um abstained from even voting on the
creation of the panel to investigate
what happened on january 6th mike rounds
is a radical we don't like mike round so
we have to remember that when we say wow
this guy's willing to accept an
incontrovertible truth we don't see him
as a friend of the left because he's not
he's still a radical
i have another chapter for you
in the maga revolt that is taking place
i told you last week that what used to
be
pro-trump and anti-trump clashes within
the republican party have now become
pro-trump versus formerly pro-trump
elements of the republican party and
this is really really good for the left
because the left has very little going
for it right now when it comes to
national political office and
campaigning as i've told you before
there's this former republican u.s
senate candidate daniel mccarthy
and we played one clip of him last week
i'll play it in a bit but i have a new
clip of him this is fascinating this is
not only a former maga guy
it's a former maga guy
who has woken up
to exactly
the truth about donald trump he's a
fraud
he's a sham
and he's a liar now mixed in with that
there's all sorts of lies that daniel
mccarthy still believes but it's
incredible how what we've known all
along about trump this guy is now waking
up to
listen
listen read between the lines right i
mean you have to understand this guy's
still a radical right winger but listen
to the critique he levies about donald
trump here so i want to make it clear to
all you people out there that are
potentially watching this that are you
know kind of haters in regards to oh
yeah oh trump would oh trump's uh part
of a master operation or some some uh 4d
chess or any of that nonsense no trump
is a fraud that's fascinating
for years these maga people like this
guy
were when trump would seemingly do
something hair brained they would say
this guy is playing some version of 40
chess he's got all the moves figured out
in advance and now daniel mccarthy is
like there's no 4d chess the guy is
genuinely a fraud and he's right
you were frauded yes and it's time to
move on quickly i think the term is
defrauded but i mean he's right he's
completely right and the republicans
should move on quickly
and it's time to expose him as hashem
and move on uh and potentially he should
be held accountable like the rest of
these criminals yes that have
perpetrated this fraud on the american
people that's a magga a magat i think
sometimes people call them
he has woken up you you know you talk
about going woke he has become woke to
the sham and scam and fraud
that is donald trump
and it's amazing that it took this long
but he's absolutely and completely right
i mean there's there's just no way
around it now this is the clip from last
week and here you'll see
you'll see the maga shine through
because daniel mccarthy dips in and out
of statements that make sense and
complete and utter lies remember this
hey donald trump this is daniel mccarthy
in arizona the world is waking up to
your massive grift please stop with the
smoke and mirrors with these audits stop
with your fundraising yes stop
establishment candidate endorsements
true stop pushing this gene therapy now
there he goes off the rails the vaccines
are not gene therapy the sauce i hear
you're coming to florence arizona for
another one of your do nothing rah-rah
session rallies that's exactly what they
are they are do nothing rah-rah rallies
he he's completely right about that well
i have an offer for you i will give one
million dollars to the charity of your
choice
if you take 30 minutes of your stage
time on january 15th
and debate me or answer my questions
even in front of your crowd think about
all the things that you've done that
you've got you've not been held
accountable for you ushered in medical
tyranny no that's not true
you exploded our national debt that is
true
you relinquished our sovereignty with
the usmca trade deal that is untrue
you passed more gun laws than obama did
with fixed knicks unclear you warned
about election fraud but yet you did
nothing to prevent it even after my team
months in advance warned you after we
were stolen from in the senate primary
you gave up on therapeutics and you push
in experimental gene therapy okay anyway
so he didn't push experimental gene
therapy or anything like that and as i
played for you last week this guy um
ultimately uh uses a flamethrower to
burn the maga hat so listen i i it it's
horrible that this is what we have to
look at as as signs of light but this is
really good for the left it's not just
pro and anti-trump republicans it's
formerly pro-trump republicans turning
against trump we want this happening
right now
some trumpists have abandoned trump alex
jones is furious with trump
former maga guy daniel mccarthy is
furious trump is feuding with mitch
mcconnell and he's still attacking his
own former vice president mike pence
this is a good thing and it will be very
interesting to see the approach that
trump takes at this weekend's rally
we'll be live with it
um trump speaks at 9pm east
we will be live at 8pm east on all of
our online platforms and i hope that
you'll join me uh send me your thoughts
about this find me on twitter at d
pacman and let me know what you think
about trump on former trump violence
one of our sponsors is nebia who's
introducing their newest shower head the
nebia by moan cuatro it was designed by
former nasa engineers who spent years
researching how to save water quattro is
the world's best high pressure water
saving shower head starting at just 119
and quattro uses 40 to 50 percent less
water than traditional shower heads
helping the planet helping your wallet
still giving you the high pressure water
stream you love with four different
spray modes literally takes one to two
minutes to install easy as screwing in a
light bulb i love it i have the rain
shower version i've been using nebia
shower heads for a while now i love
saving the water and i love the high
pressure spray it's really the best of
both worlds nebia the maker of quattro
also offers sustainable bathroom
accessories i have the soft gray bath
mat and the nebia double shelf the
quattro showerhead is just 119 dollars
but nebia is giving you 10 off when you
go to nebia.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman the
link is underneath this video the david
pakman show depends directly on the
support of our viewers and listeners
grab a membership at
joinpackman.com i we have so much to
cover i won't even say more about
membership i have not talked about um
white house press secretary jen saki's
press briefings for a while i've just
been so busy with different elements of
the show i haven't been watching them i
haven't been covering but yes covering
them but yesterday i did get an
opportunity to see kind of what was
going on and uh something the more
things change the more things stay the
same both jen saki and fox news reporter
peter ducey have had coved they are both
back and peter ducey is once again
attempting these takedowns of gensake
and of biden policy on kovid now there
is no shortage of criticism of the
united states uh both under trump and
under biden when it comes to covet
policy missteps made under both without
playing false equivalency what trump did
is unconscionable in a completely
different way than the way that that joe
biden has not been as good as he could
have been when it comes to covet policy
but peter ducey tries to in order to
score points against gensake
um starts pushing anti-vaxx talking
points like
vaccinated people are getting it too
which of course
is a very dangerous talking point in the
abstract to promote given the level of
anti-vaccine sentiment in the united
states given the incredibly significant
protection that vaccines provide against
hospitalization and death so let's just
jump right in and i think this is an
example of gensake doing a pretty good
job of refuting these toxic talking
points and
i understand that the science says that
vaccines prevent death
but
on triple backs still got coveted your
triple backs still got cobit why is the
president still referring to this as a
pandemic of the unvaccinated and of
course the answer uh we'll we'll see
what gensake says
the answer is
it's disproportionately the unvaccinated
who have to go to the hospital who end
up being intubated and who end up dying
even though now
most of the country
by most i don't mean eighty ninety
percent but sixty something percent most
of the country is vaccinated it is still
overwhelmingly the unvaccinated that are
getting really sick that's what it means
okay now let's listen to jensaki
well i think peter there's a significant
difference between and you just you just
experienced this and not to expose your
public health experience but i can speak
to mo mine as well i had been triple
vaxxed i had minor symptoms there is a
huge difference between that and being
unvaccinated you are 17 times more
likely to go to the hospital if you're
not vaccinated 20 times more likely to
die and those are significant serious
statistics so yes the impact
for people who are unvaccinated is far
more dire than those who are vaccinated
will the president update his language
at some time to be more reflective of
the fact that people who are triple
vaccinated are catching and spreading
colvin i think people president has said
as have we a number of times that there
will be breakthrough cases there will be
people who get kovid
here
at different media organizations at
companies around the world uh around the
country uh who have been vaccinated but
there is a significant difference
between being hospitalized or dying and
being vaccinated with more mild symptoms
so what you have to understand is that
peter ducey is there to try to
goad
um jensaki into sound bites for the
purposes of later airing them on fox
news and showing how great he did the
questions are dumb and they're bad
questions by design
because they're so stupid that the idea
is fire up gen saki so she says
something emotional or looks bad in some
way
he is not actually there to be a
reporter and to bring information to
people his argument essentially is
seat belt laws haven't completely
eliminated traffic deaths and also
sometimes even when you're wearing a
seat belt you can still get hurt in a
car accident that's basically the
argument and if you said that to most
people they would say that's a really
stupid argument against seat belts isn't
it this is the most important of the
three things that he kind of tries to
pull we'll look at a couple others in a
moment
the unvaccinated in the u.s
are more likely to test positive so you
you still do get protection against
omicron from being
triple vaccinated but it is so
contagious and it's different enough
from what the vaccines target that a lot
of vaccinated people still uh
ultimately test positive but they are
significantly less likely to end up in
the hospital and significantly less
likely to die it's sort of like a false
equivalency where he goes listen
unvaccinated people get this and
vaccinated people get this so it's the
same well no you have to actually look
at the numbers and see what it is that
we're talking about here and the issue
is they are coming to their conclusion
first which is we don't like the vaccine
we want to talk about being against it
not juicy personally right his shtick is
i got it but people are asking this
question because he's doing it for the
audience they start with we don't want
the vaccine and then they work backwards
from there then they also talked about
coveted testing i'll just show you a
little bit of that jay i was home all
last week isolating welcome back thank
you i was isolating with covid after a
positive test like a lot of people
watching
and a lot of time in front of the tv i
heard the president say did you watch
fox the whole time or other things i
have exhausted the full catalogue of guy
fieri content oh okay
and obviously a lot of [ __ ] but i heard
the president say
google covet test near me so
somebody isolating with covid i did that
and the appointments everywhere were
completely jammed so why is it that you
guys were so unprepared
for the
need for testing after the holidays
well peter i'm happy to see you back and
well um i would second say that there
has been a massive surge in cases as you
know and we're a part of in dc and new
york and there's been an unprecedented
in other parts of the country as well
there's been an unprecedented demand for
tests so what we have done over the
course of the last few weeks even before
okay so you know it's another gotcha
and it is absolutely true that testing
is a disaster in the united states it's
been a disaster for a long time uh and
um
it it's the the problem here is the
continued um attempt to
give people who watch fox fodder for
justifying not only not getting
vaccinated not even looking for a test
when they have symptoms
and then here's the last one this one is
on sonia sotomayor you guys have been
very aggressive countering covet
misinformation so what do you guys think
about cove and misinformation coming
from the supreme court it's kind of
weird that he even talks like this you
know it's like
it
what do you guys think about uh it's
sort of like the way you would talk it's
like the way a third grader would talk
to the teacher when they have a joke you
know and sonia sotomayor's false claim
that over a hundred thousand children
are in serious condition many on
ventilators
well i'm not going to speak to supreme
court arguments or statements uh made in
those arguments uh but i will tell you
that what is at stake here is our effort
to protect health workers and most
importantly protect patients
so
you know again it's not that it's
invalid to touch on these issues but
it's all meaningless gotcha you're not
really informing anyone by asking the
white house press secretary about a
misstatement made by a supreme court
justice it's it's just optics and trying
to goad responses and gensake continuing
to do a pretty good job a pretty good
job of dealing with it hey this is going
to be a lesson for some of our younger
viewers some of our younger viewers may
be totally unfamiliar with or not super
familiar with a woman named sarah palin
who was once the vice president she was
almost the vice president of the united
states were it not for voters choosing
barack obama over the late senator john
mccain in the 2008 presidential election
sarah palin
could have been the first female vice
president of the united states and she
would have been a horrible vice
president because she's an incompetent
clown
now she has resurfaced and i am going to
play an unbelievable video for you
she went on fox news to weigh in on the
aoc controversy the aoc controversy is
she
is for
i'm trying to even understand the
controversy she's four coveted
guidelines being followed and being
enacted
but she went to florida
um
and her partner didn't wear shoes i'm
sorry he wore flip-flops sitting outside
at a restaurant and then she got covered
and there's been all sorts of wacky
responses uh to to
her going to florida and getting coveted
one of the things that she said she
being aoc
that i think came off as a little bit
pompous to be completely honest is she
says the people the republicans
criticizing her want to date her
and this is just so funny sarah palin
we've covered her for so long because
she ran in you know 2008.
sarah palin loses the ability to
communicate in english she has these
situations where she's like visibly
struggling to use language to
communicate anything of meaning and it
happened again and she weirdly says that
liberals want to pound
the idea of sex
into the minds of people see if you can
even follow what sarah palin is saying
here this is this is wild
it amazes me though her and other
liberals
socialists even their ability to what
socialist is she talking about flat from
what the issues truly are and here her
obsession with at least suggestions of
them always gender and sex even it um
you know i truly believe that there are
enough americans who get it and
understand what her tactic is and that
is to deflect from what the real issues
are but uh yeah okay take this issue
though with her suggestion of dating and
if you're wondering what she's talking
about
everybody is this is how sarah palin
communicates it's completely unclear
what she's talking about and here we get
into pounding
and you know attraction to someone and
blaming her failures on that
that obsession with sex look how the
liberals rachel uh want to
pound that into the public's head
that
advertising who is attracted to who what
people do in their own the privacy of
their own bedrooms um all those things
that have to do with it it's really
funny to hear sarah palin
who participated in an anti-gay campaign
in 2008 as vice president you know on
religious grounds now saying others are
talking about what people are doing in
their private bedrooms that that's
really funny
privacy and sex the liberals not the
conservatives are the one who pound
pound pound after that and um obviously
it's a tactic so that she doesn't have
to be held accountable it sounds like
they just want a pound pound pound about
sex and things in bedrooms and this we
were used to this sarah palin for a long
time complete word salads and just as a
little history lesson for our younger
viewers
i'm going to play a clip for you of
sarah palin this is from 2014
okay
this is how regularly incoherent she's
always been see if you can follow what
she's saying here
we believe
wait i thought fast food joints
don't you guys think that they're like
of the devil or something that's what
liberals you want to send those evil
employees who would dare work at a fast
food joint that you just don't believe
in thought you wanted to you know send
them to purgatory or something what so
they all go vegan
and uh
wages and picket lines i don't know
they're not often discussed in purgatory
are they i don't know why are you even
worried about fast food wages because
this has not been edited or doctored in
any way this is this is the original
thing she said
well we believe
in america where minimum wage jobs
they're not lifetime gigs they're
stepping stone
okay so then there's me from from 2014.
uh that is the sarah palin that we have
been used to for a long time visibly
struggling to use the english language
and for our younger viewers you can go
to our youtube channel
and check out some of our older clips uh
it's probably time for her to disappear
for another eight years because these
appearances are not going well
make sure that you're following us on
instagram at david pakman show we will
have these clips there if you have just
been listening today we'll take a quick
break and be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
today we're going to be speaking with
janis varufakas who is the former
finance minister of greece professor of
economics at the university of athens
co-founder of the international
grassroots movement and also author of
several several books including most
recently another now dispatches from an
alternative present uh great to have you
today i appreciate it
thank you david thank you so to start
with um the the current pandemic we've
seen a number of different
aspects of the global economy exposed by
the pandemic including the fragility of
supply chains
the fragility of the sort of social
welfare apparatus in many different
countries when employees get sick and
can't come to work we've seen the
world's debt increase significantly
when you think about the last two years
and the pandemic's effect on the global
economy what are your big concerns and
takeaways
well there are many
changes and disasters
at the quantitative
level so things that were already bad
got much much worse so if you were a
precariously employed worker
your life became
even more miserable than it was
within our countries and between our
countries inequalities have skyrocketed
but that's a quantitative effect
we had these problems before they've
been magnified if you think about it the
crisis which begun in wall street in
2008
and caused the fed the european central
bank the central banks of the world
to band together
and start printing mountain ranges of
money
in order to support financial sectors
that what happened effectively in the
first
semester of 2009 under obama golden
brown in england and so on
was effectively
states central banks replaced private
profit in order to float the financial
sector that caused huge inequalities
those who were in the money markets
never had it so good those who were not
suffered suffered the permanent
stagnation the kobe 19 exacerbated that
turbocharged that
but
we are now in the process
of another major shock to the system
which is a qualitative shock because
between 2009 and 2020 the central banks
have been stabilizing
the financial markets
in the way that they just described
in the way that we're all familiar with
but now
they are
between
a rock and a hard place the central
banks why because
they have zombified states
and corporations so
my the my country the government of my
country is completely zombified it's
totally bankrupt and relies on the
central bank of europe to keep printing
money to keep it afloat to a large
extent you could even say that
to a lesser extent but to a large extent
about the federal government united
states
your debt relies to a very large extent
on the fed's capacity and willingness to
continue to
roll it over
same in england the same thing in japan
to a large extent
but
because of the disruption of the supply
chains that you mentioned
and the fact that we now have serious
cost push inflation cost push inflation
not the bond pool cost push inflation
that is putting them in
in a dumped if they do dumped if they
don't situation central banks if they
continue to refloat the financial
markets are going to be fueling
inflation which is creating significant
political and social problems
if they stop doing that then
corporations and states that rely on
this
extending and pretending of their debt
are going to go under
and this is going to be the qualitative
effect that we are going to be
remembering in 10 20 years
time
regarding this period this juncture so
in the united states and in other
countries when you talk about deficit
spending
sometimes there's two very different
views you have people on one side who
say deficit spending is is always bad
you have people on the other side who
sometimes say deficit spending doesn't
really matter if you never have to pay
it back and sometimes there's a more
balanced view or it sounds balanced
which is
deficit spending can be okay
if it's on economically stimulative
programs that over the long term are
good for for the economy can you talk a
little bit about
what are the limits of some of these
ideas in the context of inflation and
the other things that you're talking
about here
allow me to start by being a little bit
cynical please know it is against that
if it finances them
so the
you know even even very conservative
republicans in 2008 when the bottom fell
out of wall street
they went straight to the state 200
and to george w bush and they said give
us money
you know we don't care where you get it
borrow it print it the very
conservatives who were against
deficit spending uh okay cynicism aside
right
look it's it's capitalism without debt
is like christianity without hell
it
so of course the nuanced position that
you put forward right at the end
is the sensible one
that if you use deficit
spending
that fueled
investment
properly correctly
sensibly that is the obviously good
thing to do
now the problem however is
that
it's now 13 years since 2008
and during those 13 years
just by saying this it concentrates the
mind
we've never had so much money
floating around
in the history of humanity
never before humanity as a whole
has been saving 30 percent of its income
not so much the americans and the greeks
but the chinese the world generally
right corporations look at apple they've
got 200 what some like 200 billion
dollars saved i mean it's insane that
the corporation should have savings
corporations should have debts they
should be borrowing to invest when apple
has 200 billion you know of stash
you know there's a problem with
capitalism so for you know 13 years now
we've had all this money slashing around
okay
it's very
inequitably distributed but humanity
in total we have all this money
in comparison to the liquidity which is
available we've never had such low
levels of investment
so yeah
if you go to sierra leone
or to greece you know countries that are
poor and bankrupt
sierra leone and more than greece but
nevertheless you know what i mean yes i
mean you're going to
it makes perfect sense it's not pleasant
but it makes perfect sense that
investment is low
but
when you look at countries like germany
which is swimming in money swimming in
money never
in the history of germany did germany
have so much money and yet their level
of investment in things that they need
like you know
5g
renewables
things that they actually need
they still use fax machines in their
ministries
this is true uh in the united states
infrastructure is dilapidated you have
huge quantities of money
very low levels of investment and that
has been the case now for 13 years now
you know what this means it means that
as a species we failed to
make use of available resources
in order to generate our capacity to
weather storms economic storms coveted
climate change
so now
to start worrying about uh
debt
it is a bit too little too late in a
sense so to those who say oh but look at
the you know the the the fed continues
to print money and the federal
government is uh running a huge deficit
yeah but you know what
you were not worried when wall street
was creating gigantic quantities of
private debt before 2008 that blew up
the world right
landed us where we are so
let's focus on the one thing that really
matters
investment
investment in things that human beings
need
and i'm not talking about suvs i'm not
talking about you know more airports i'm
talking about renewable energy i'm
talking about artificial intelligence
that can actually help us rather than
enslave us i'm talking about
social care i'm talking about healthcare
education the things that will make life
for humans better on this planet and
which will allow this planet to continue
to allow us to exist on it in terms of
climate change
how do i mean we might not know the
answer to this yet but how do countries
where things are really a disaster
get out of those situations and i'll
give you so you mentioned sierra leone
you talked about greece which you have
first-hand experience with i'm from
argentina argentina now has had
uh
administration after administration
admin after administration of disastrous
different types of policy none of which
has served the vast majority of the
people and the problems continue to get
worse and worse
do we know for sure yet
in sort of the modern world that
countries can truly get out of these
disastrous situations and if so what are
the types of paths out
oh we certainly can
because you know as i said before it's
not that we don't have the money
or the resources this is this is why we
are a stupid species
because we are not in pecunius we have
the resources we have the money the
savings are there we're just not putting
it into use i mean think about it just
for one second david if i may say this
please
for the last 13 years okay in order to
stimulate the economy our central banks
have been printing money
let's not judge them for that they've
been printing money the question is what
did they do with this yes they gave it
to bank of america to deutsche bank
right to barclays bank and what did
these banks do they looked at little
people out there medium-sized businesses
small businesses they said no no we're
not going to trust them with the money
so they picked up the phone and they
called google apple volkswagen siemens
who already have money sitting there
doing nothing and they said to them look
we'll give it to you for free
because you know the commercial banks
got it from the central banks at
negative interest rates or next to
nothing right
so yeah apple said okay give it to me
i'm not going to invest it because if i
wanted to invest i would have invested
my own money so they take the money and
they go to the stock exchange and they
buy back their own shares right
insurance prices go up this is a
complete waste this is not creating
things that humanity needs
so yes we can get out of it
countries like the united states like
germany and so on should do what
roosevelt did in 1933
with a new deal use public finance in
order to press into the service of
things humanity needs
the existing money
when it comes to countries like
argentina and greece
well we have a common fate
we have a debt that we can never repay
never never i mean even if god and her
angels descend upon the planet
and they they cannot repay that debt it
cannot be repaid right so that is not
cannot be repaid it has to be haircut
has to be you know it's what wall street
banks do
every day they restructure that
they cut it so we need to have debt
forgiveness
for countries that cannot repay them
because
you know
even from a selfish perspective of rich
countries
the only way they can get some money
back of what argentina or greece owes
them is if there is growth and there can
never be any growth if you have the
hedge funds you have the new york judges
the international monetary fund
pressurizing the government of argentina
to continue to squeeze the people of
argentina
right it's like beating up
a sick cow expect to get more milk
you're not going to get more milk the
cow will die yes it's a clever strategy
um do you believe that we are
already in a post-capitalist world
i have been known to say that yes this
is what my next book is going to be
about um i'm already putting out there
this view uh look i'm i'm a lefty right
let's
you know full disclosure yes lefty we
left this we're brought to this world
thinking
in uh infinite stupidity that um we came
here to overthrow capitalism and to
replace it by socialism and to our
consternation
we discover or i'm discovering now that
capitalism did it itself it overthrew
itself and now we have something which
is much closer to feudalism uh and you
know
my fellow leftists hate me for saying
this because
they think that my goodness you know if
if we are not here to overthrow
capitalism what's our purpose in life
and the answer is um
you know to to come clean and to accept
that now capitalism has been allowed to
a very large extent by the failures of
the left over decades and centuries
to morph into something far more
oppressive
far more exploitative and far more
dangerous for the human species
i call it techno feudalism
talk about what you mean by that techno
feudalism well
okay um
think of what happens the moment you
enter amazon.com
you exit capitalism
you enter something that resembles
a feudal thief victim
because it's a digital world belonging
to one man and his algorithm
his algorithm determines what product
you're going to see what part of the
program
product you are not going to see
if you're a seller how you can sell it
how you cannot sell it
whom you can approach amongst the
customers whom not
imagine it is a little bit like walking
outside
your building now and discovering that
the city in which you are
every single building belongs to one
person
the air belongs to that person the
pavement belongs to the person and that
person also has a capacity to turn your
head to ensure that he's you see what he
wants you to see that's not capitalism
it's not even monopoly capitalism it is
a digital feudalism a techno feudalism
and if you think that already going back
to what we were saying earlier
central bank money has replaced private
profits
so
profits have been replaced by central
bank money and markets have are being in
the process of being replaced by digital
platforms if you take profit and markets
out of capitalism you don't have
capitalism
you have something i'd call
technofeudalism we're gonna pause our
interview there with former finance
minister of greece janis varufakis for
the full interview head on over to our
youtube channel at youtube.com
slash the david pakman show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show all right it uh
that
i am really really frustrated with uh
what i'm about to tell you
we have been banned from facebook's
video monetization for 90 days 90 days
because of anti-vaxx content now i know
all of you are probably saying wait
david
antivax what on earth are you talking
about you have been following the
science on vaccines and explaining the
effectiveness of these vaccines andy i
know
i know believe me but we have been
banned from facebook's monetization for
90 days and i'm going to explain to you
why in a second now the back story here
of course is
we
know
that at the flip of a switch we can lose
entire sources of revenue for our
program how do we know that because it's
happened
adpocalypse took place in april of 2017
when as a result of an ad playing on a
racist youtube video that had nothing to
do with us
youtube and advertisers essentially
switched off advertising on news and
politics content for close to two months
we lost
99.98
of our youtube revenue for nearly two
months
and that made us realize we've got to
diversify we've got to diversify that's
why we started streaming on twitch
that's why we started posting all of our
content to facebook instead of just a
clip or two a day
now about a year ago we lost
monetization for seven days from
facebook and we never found out why we
were told
you violated community guidelines well
which which post couldn't find out what
did we say couldn't find out but it was
only seven days so we just decided to
wait it out but we were told
if this happens again and it's like if
what happens again if this happens again
you will lose monetization for 90 days
now because we have decided to diversify
revenue sources
because of what's happened in the past
facebook has grown to be close to 20
percent of our revenue
and we have now lost that 20 percent for
three months
what is the post that caused this
i will show it to you
we covered
early last week
the
conflict
between alex jones and donald trump
donald trump now has been advocating
more
more more publicly for the vaccine
alex jones is anti-vaccine and turned on
donald trump so we posted
is this where trump's base is going to
draw the line and we linked to our video
alex jones loses it on trump jones
against vaccine trump pro this is
creating a rift and of course the things
alex jones said in the video gene
therapies killing people we said all of
these things are lies
that got us banned from facebook
monetization for 90 days 90 days
um
this is
close to 20 of our revenue now
and of course
it is a complete and total
misunderstanding we aren't anti-vaxx now
i know there are people who are gonna
hear this i already i'm imagining the
comments on on youtube
david this is your just desserts
this is what you deserve david because
you've been cheering
for people being
canceled from facebook or youtube or
whatever no no no no no
i hope that some of you are
sophisticated enough to understand what
is going on here versus what we've
talked about in the past
i am 100
respectful of the fact that facebook
youtube twitter whoever can establish
their terms and conditions for what is
allowed on the platform facebook is
completely right to say we're not going
to allow the spread of coveted
disinformation they still allow it but
they are completely right to say that
will be our policy the problem here
isn't that it's that it's not being
applied correctly we are obviously not
an anti-vaccine show
so all the people oh but david you said
you they they're coming for you now this
is what you deserve no no no
they're not coming for me for anything
we actually did i respect that facebook
can have an enforced terms and
conditions we just didn't violate them
this is a mistake and there's no
recourse to get it reversed there's no
way to get a hold of anyone at facebook
so
if you actually
work or have someone you know that works
at facebook that could help with this
please email info davidpakman.com don't
send me a link to a form where i can
submit if we've done that facebook
doesn't respond to any of that stuff
okay i've reached out to every i asked
jenk yuger hey do you have a contact i
asked our youtube rep it's like why i'm
like listen i know you work for google
not facebook but do you happen to know
anyone at facebook if you actually work
there or know someone who might be able
to help but there is every indication
that for three months
we are losing
uh 20 of our revenue and i know some of
you will say screw facebook we don't
need it if we
don't work to have our content there
we are giving more space to the actual
right wing disinformation that spreads
uncontrolled on facebook so i know it's
easy to say just get off the platform
the platform is huge and we are on there
to try to fight the trash that is spread
like wildfire on facebook so all i can
ask you is help us make up for that 20
we're gonna lose for three months grab a
membership on my website uh that that
that's really the the one ask i have
um 20 for three months is that's a big
chunk you know we we've got a number of
employees now and a lot of different
things that we're doing and 20 is a big
deal we've created a coupon code it's
kind of a joke it's facebook with two fs
you know f facebook okay yeah that's
it's a joke okay but um you can go to
joinpakman.com
use the code facebook you'll get a
discount and hopefully we can make up a
little bit of this lost 20 but an
absolutely
devastating thing devastating thing and
i'll keep people posted about it
um urine therapy urine yes urine the
bodily fluid urine uh christopher keys
who is another one of these covid
conspiracists he's an anti-vaxx leader
of sorts he is now urging followers to
drink their own urine to fight covid
let's take a look at the clip
this is quite vile and also incredibly
stupid take a look at this
the antidote that we've seen now and we
have tons and tons of research
is
urine therapy that's right folks you are
not don't adjust your television he is
saying urine you are ine
okay
and i know to a lot of you
a lot of you this sounds crazy right but
guys god's given us everything we need
okay
and i'm gonna give you again
i test and prove all things okay
um
this has been around for centuries um
we've got research after research
documented peer-reviewed published
papers on your end now it is true that
there are peer-reviewed published papers
about urine
it's not about urine curing kovid now
understand that there's a backstory to
this there's a backstory to all of these
ideas there's a like a recycling of old
ideas going on urine has been promoted
in the past for treating cancer cancer
society says there's no evidence of
therapeutic use of urine
people talk about irrigating your
sinuses with a neti pot some people use
distilled filtered water for the neti
pot there's the idea of using urine
running urine through your sinuses
brushing your teeth with urine that's an
interesting one um applying urine
directly to the skin for some kind of
skin treatment
the source of all of this is a simple
idea that there are certain tumor
proteins present in the urine of cancer
patients and the idea came from if you
introduce urine
into the body in different ways then the
body will start to make antibodies
against the tumor proteins and it might
destroy the cancer or have other
benefits it's all bogus it's true that
urine can contain tumor antigens there's
no evidence that shows that drinking it
using it for massages using it to bake a
cake bathing in it or any other urine
applications actually does any of the
things that it's claimed to do now i
want to be thorough here when we talk
about urine we need to be thorough
there is one possible
bridge use of urine
for health purposes okay now does
anybody know what it is
if you are completely dehydrated and
without water and you're on the verge of
dying
urine is 95 water
there is some belief that for the very
short term you might be able to survive
in a at a point of catastrophic
dehydration
by drinking your urine for a day or
maybe two okay
urine
in a general sense it's 95 water it's
safe to drink it will replenish some
lost water
the problem is that that other five
percent that's not water
isn't stuff you want a lot of in your
body you're basically taking the stuff
your kidneys have filtered out and
you're putting it back in and it'll end
up back in your kidneys and you can end
up with really really bad symptoms from
long-term drinking of urine but if
you're in a completely desperate
situation no water
you're close to death it's conceivable
that drinking your own urine might let
you survive just a little bit until you
get rescued or whatever there's actually
uh the book 437 days about the
fisherman salvador alvarenga who drifted
offshore in mexico ended up in the
pacific islands at some brief periods he
drank his own urine but he very quickly
figured out how to collect rainwater he
would not have been able to survive
just drinking urine for 437 days so
that's the truth about so-called urine
therapy christopher key's dangerous
conspiracist not to be followed we have
a voicemail number that number is 219 to
david p
here is a mind-blowing voicemail
with a hypothesis about how i didn't get
covered but my girlfriend did as i
talked about last week i don't know that
anything in this voicemail is based in
science but it is an entertaining
hypothesis let's listen to it together
hey david i listen to your show on your
girlfriend with the coveted exposure and
i have a possible solution for you
it wasn't an issue of her infecting you
with an issue of you infecting her okay
your brother and you share the same
genetics and all probability you picked
it up from your brother what i'm finding
here
around me is that people that have got
high levels of protection
are still picking up the virus
and they can still extrude virus in
micro doses essentially is how to think
about it
extrusion of micro doses wow
but they're not producing enough
for the viral protein to trigger the um
cova test
so in your situation where your your
girlfriend seemed better than worse
better than worse type of situation
um what i think happened was your
brother infected you guys when you were
in the car
when you went home her genetics
responded her way your protection and
genetics responded its way and brother
and you obviously share the same so all
of this is absolutely fascinating and
entertaining i don't know that there's
anything here based in science so like
one idea first of all the idea that it's
my brother who was the exposure point my
brother tested tested tested after this
it doesn't seem like he had covered it
it doesn't seem like he had it nor that
he got it the other thing is
i don't know that there's any evidence
that if you're exposed by someone with
whom you share genetic material like a
brother that you're less likely to get
it from them than an exposure from a
person with whom you don't share genetic
material i i've it's it's endlessly
entertaining i just don't know that
there's any facts here very similar
so during that time frame you were sick
you weren't sick enough to actually
produce enough protein to trigger the
positive test she was remembered the
test is looking at viral rna not viral
protein as we talked about yesterday so
there's some some question marks here
about this explanation reacting to that
because you guys both work from home and
you're both
in such a closed space and you're living
as a couple
you essentially were micro dosing her on
a regular basis
so it was a situation of very little
over a long period of time that's why
she had her ups and downs
it it it's fascinating i don't know that
there's anything there that's actually
backed by science but a fascinating
fascinating explanation on today's bonus
show the u.s russia talks have ended and
no progress has been made we will also
talk about the first ever heart
transplant from a genetically edited pig
fascinating and john ossoff will
introduce a bill
banning members of congress from owning
from trading individual stocks all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show
sign up at join
pacman.com and we will see you then
you